on c-span's american perspectives
american perspectives wraps up tonight
with a 1945 speech from robert
oppenheimer today marks the 60th
anniversary of the bombing of hiroshima
dr oppenheimer directed the manhattan
project which produced the bombs that
fell on hiroshima and nagasaki
effectively ending world war ii
this is an audio recording of a speech
he gave in november 1945 at the
university of pennsylvania it's 20
minutes
members of the academy members of the
philosophical society
but you have good reason to wish to hear
from me today
what circumstances have perhaps
qualified me to discuss with you on the
basis of experience
is how to make atomic weapons
it is true as we have so often and so
earnestly said
that in the scientific studies which we
had to carry out at los alamos in the
practical arts there developed there was
little fundamental discovery
there was no great new insight into the
nature of the physical world
but we had many surprises we learned a
good many things about atomic nuclei and
many more about the behavior of matter
under extreme and unfamiliar conditions
and not too few of the undertakings were
in their quality and their style
worthy of the best traditions of
physical science
it would not be a dull story it is being
recorded in a great handbook of 15
volumes
much of which we think will be of
interest to scientists even if they are
not by profession makers of atomic bombs
it would be a pleasure to tell you a
little about it
it would be a pleasure to help you to
share our pride in the adequacy and the
soundness of the physical science of our
common heritage that went into this
weapon that proved itself last summer in
the new mexico desert
that would not be adele's story but it
is not one that i can tell today
it would be too dangerous to tell that
story
that is what the president on behalf of
the people of the united states has told
us
that is what many of us
where we forced ourselves to make the
decision might well conclude
what has come upon us that the insight
the knowledge the power of physical
science to the cultivation of which to
the learning and teaching of which we
are dedicated has become too dangerous
to be talked of even in these halls
it is that question that faces us now
it goes to the root of what science is
and what its value is it is to that
question to which tentatively partially
and with a profound sense of its
difficulty and my own inadequacy i must
try to speak today
it is not a familiar question to us in
these late days
it is not a familiar situation if it
seems to bear analogy to that raised by
other weapons
to the need for a certain secrecy let us
say in the discussion of howitzers or of
torpedoes
that analogy will mislead us
there are some accidents in this
situation
some things that may in the large light
of history seem contingent
atomic weapons are based on things that
are in the very frontier of physics
their development is inextricably
entangled with the growth of physics
as in all probability without of the
biological sciences and many practical
arts
atomic weapons were actually made by
scientists even some of you may think by
scientists normally committed to the
exploration of rather recondite things
the speed of the development the active
and essential participation of men of
science in the development have no doubt
contributed greatly to our awareness of
the crisis that faces us
even to our sense of responsibility for
its resolution
but these are contingent things
what is not contingent is that we have
made a thing
a most terrible weapon
that has altered abruptly and profoundly
the nature of the world
we have made a thing that by all the
standards of the world we grew up in is
an evil thing
and by so doing by our participation in
making it possible to make these things
we have raised again the question of
whether science is good for man whether
it is good to learn about the world to
try to understand it to try to control
it to help give to the world of men
increased insight
increased power
because we are scientists we must say an
unalterable yes to these questions
it is our faith and our commitment
seldom made explicit even more seldom
challenged that knowledge is a good in
itself knowledge and such powers must
come with it
one will perhaps think back to the early
days of physical science in western
culture when it was felt as so deep a
threat to the whole christian world
one will remember the more recent times
of the last century where such a threat
was seen by some in the new
understanding of the relations between
man and the rest of the living world
one may even remember the concern among
the learned that some of the fundamental
developments of physics the theory of
relativity and even more the ideas of
complementarity
and their far-reaching implications on
the relations of common sense and of
scientific discovery
they're enforced reminder familiar to
hindu culture but rather foreign to that
of europe
of the latent inadequacies of human
conceptions to the real world they must
describe
one may think of these things and
especially of the great conflicts of the
renaissance
because they reflect the truth that
science is a part of the world of men
that often before it is injected into
that world elements of instability and
change
that if there is peril in the situation
today as i believe there is we may look
to the past for reassurance that our
faith and the value of knowledge can
prevail
an atomic bomb is not a new conception a
new discovery of reality it is a very
ordinary thing in some ways compact with
much of the science that makes our
laboratories and our industry
but it will change men's lives as over
the centuries the knowledge of the solar
system has changed them for in a world
of atomic weapons wars will cease
and that is not a small thing not small
in itself as the world knows today
perhaps more bitterly than ever before
but perhaps in the end even greater in
the alterations the radical of slow
alterations in the relations between men
and between nations and cultures that it
implies
it can only help us i believe to
recognize these issues as rather great
issues
we can serve neither ourselves nor the
cause of the freedom and growth of
science or our fellow men
if we underestimate the difficulties
or if we through cowardice becloud the
radical character of the conflict and
its issue
during our lifetime perhaps atomic
weapons could be either a great or a
small trouble
they cannot be a small hope
they can be a great one
sometimes when men speak of the great
hope and the great promise of the field
of atomic energy
they speak not of peace but of atomic
power and of nuclear radiations
certainly these are proper enthusiasms
enthusiasms that we must all share
the technical feasibility of deriving
virtually unlimited amounts of power
from controlled nuclear reactors seems
very certain
very nearly certain
and the realization of plants to
demonstrate the advantages and
limitations of such power does not seem
from the point of view of technical
effort remote
when we must look at history to learn
that such possibilities will in time be
found of value will in time come to plan
important even at this even if at this
moment not thoroughly understood part in
our industry and our economy
you have heard this morning of some of
the biological and medical problems and
uses of radiation from such reactors
even physicists can think of some
instructive things to do with the grams
of neutrons such reactors make available
and all of us who have seen something of
the growth of science know very well
that what we can discern the
possibilities in these fields is a very
small part of what will turn up when we
really get into them
nevertheless it would seem somewhat
wrong to me to let our confidence in my
view our wholly justified confidence in
the future of the peaceful applications
of nuclear physics
distract us entirely from the immediacy
and the peril of atomic weapons
it would not be on us to do so for not
even a better understanding of the
physical world
not even the most welcome developments
of therapy should make us content to see
these weapons turn to the devastation of
the earth
it will not even be very practical to do
so technically the operation of reactors
and the manufacture of weapons are
rather closely related wherever reactors
are in operation there is a potential
source
though not necessarily a convenient one
of materials for weapons
wherever materials are made for weapons
they can be used for reactors that may
be well suited to research or power
development
it would seem to me almost inevitable
that in a world committed to atomic
armament the shadow of fear secrecy
constraint and guilt would hang heavy
over much of nuclear physics much of
science
scientists in this country have been
quick to sense this and to attempt to
escape it
i do not think that this attempt can be
very successful in a world of atomic
armament
there is another set of arguments was
intended his to minimize the impact of
atomic weapons and thus to delay or to
avert the inevitably in the end radical
changes in the world which their advent
would seem to require
there are people who say that they are
not such very bad weapons before the new
mexico test we some sometimes said that
too
writing down square miles and equivalent
tonnages and looking at the pictures of
a ravaged europe
after the test we did not say it anymore
some of you will have seen photographs
of the nagasaki strike seen the great
steel girders of factories twisted and
wrecked
some of you may have noticed that these
factories that were wrecked were many
miles apart
some of you will have seen pictures of
the people who were burned or had a look
at the wastes of hiroshima
that vomit nagasaki would have taken out
ten square miles or a bit more if there
had been ten square miles to take out
because it is known that the project
costs two billion dollars and we drop
just two bombs it is easy to think they
must be very expensive
but for any serious undertaking in
atomic armament and without any elements
of technical novelty whatever just doing
things that have already been done that
estimate of cost would be high by
something like a factor of a thousand
atomic weapons even with what we know
today can be cheap
even with what we know how to do today
without any of the new things the little
things and the radical things
atomic armament will not break the back
of any people that want atomic armament
the pattern of the use of atomic weapons
was set at hiroshima
they are weapons of aggression of
surprise and of terror
if they are ever used again it may well
be by the thousands or perhaps by the
tens of thousands their method of
delivery may well be different and may
reflect new possibilities of
interception
and new efforts to outwit them
and the strategy of their use may well
be different than it was against an
essentially defeated enemy
but it is a weapon for aggressors and
the elements of surprise and of terror
are as intrinsic to it as are the
fissionable nuclei
one of our colleagues a man most deeply
committed to the welfare and the growth
of science advised me not long ago not
to give too much weight in any public
words
to the terrors of atomic weapons as they
are and as they can be
he knows as well as any of us how much
more terrible they can be made
it might he said cause a reaction
hostile to science it might turn people
away from science
he is not such an old man and i think it
will make little difference to him or to
any of us what is said now about atomic
weapons
if before we die we live to see a war in
which they are used i think that it will
not help to avert such a war if we try
to rub the edges off this new terror
that we have helped bring to the world
i think that it is for us among all men
for us as scientists perhaps in greater
measure because it is our tradition to
recognize and to accept the strange and
the new
i think it is for us to accept this fact
this new terror
and to accept with it the necessity for
those transformations in the world which
will make it possible to integrate these
developments into human life
i think we cannot in the long term
protect science against this threat to
its spirits and this reproach to its
issue
unless we recognize the threat and the
reproach and help our fellow men in
every way suitable to remove their cause
their cause is war
if i return so insistently to the
magnitude of the peril not only to
science but to our civilization it is
because i see in that our one great hope
as a further argument against war like
arguments that have always and
increasingly existed that have grown
with the gradual growth of modern
technology it is not unique
as a further matter requiring
international consideration like all
other matters that so require it it is
not unique but as a vast threat and a
new one to all the peoples of the earth
by its novelty its terror its strangely
promethean quality it has become in the
eyes of many of us
a unique opportunity
it has proven most difficult to make
those changes in the relations between
nations and peoples those concurrent and
mutually dependent changes in law in
spirit in customs and in conception
they are all essential no one of them is
absolutely prior to the others that
should make an end to war
it has not only been difficult it has
proven impossible it will be difficult
in the days ahead difficult and beset
with discouragements and frustrations
and it will be very slow
but it will not be impossible
if it is recognized as i think it should
be recognized that this for us in our
time is the fundamental problem of human
society then it will not be impossible
these are very major commitments nor
would i minimize their depth
for they involve holding prior to all
else we cherish all that we would live
for and die for
our common bond with all people
everywhere our common responsibility for
a world without war our common
confidence that in a world thus united
the things that we cherish
learning and freedom and humanity will
not be lost
these words may seem visionary but they
are not meant so it is a practical thing
to avert atomic war
it is a practical thing to recognize the
fraternity of the peoples of the world
it is a practical thing to recognize as
a common responsibility wholly incapable
of unilateral solution the completely
common peril that atomic weapons
constitute for the world
to recognize that only by a community of
responsibility is there any hope of
meeting that peril
it could be an eminently practical thing
to attempt to develop those arrangements
and that spirit of confidence between
peoples that are needed for the control
of atomic weapons it could be practical
to regard this as a pilot plant for all
those other necessary international
arrangements without which there will be
no peace
for this is a new field
less fettered than most with vested
interest or with the vast inertia of
centuries of purely national sovereignty
this is a new field growing out of a
science inspired by the highest ideals
of international fraternity
it would seem somewhat visionary and
more than a little dangerous to hope
that work on atomic energy and atomic
weapons might proceed as have so many
things in the past like the building of
battleships on a purely and narrowly
national authority without basic
confidence between peoples without
cooperation nor the abrogation that
somehow these separate distrustful
atomic arsenals would make for the peace
of the world
it would seem to me visionary in the
extreme and not practical to hope that
methods which have so sadly failed to
avert war in the past will succeed in
the face of this far greater apparel
it would in my opinion be most dangerous
to regard in these shattering times a
radical solution is less practical than
a conventional one it would also be most
dangerous and most certain to lead to
tragic discouragements to expect that a
radical solution can evolve rapidly or
that its evolution will be free of the
gravest conflicts and uncertainties
the first steps in implementing the
internationalization of responsibility
the responsibility perhaps in the first
instance for averting the perils of
an atomic war
will inevitably be very modest
it is surely not proper for me who have
neither experience nor knowledge to
speak of what such step steps might be
but there are two things that perhaps
might be born in mind that we might wish
to say as scientists
one is that not only politically but
technically this field of atomic energy
is a very new field and a very rapidly
changing one that it would be well to
stress the interim tentative character
of any arrangements that might in the
near future seem appropriate
the second is that in the encouragement
and cultivation of the exchange between
nations we would see not only an
opportunity for strengthening the
fraternity between scientists of
different lands
but a valuable aid in establishing
confidence among the nations as to their
interests and activities in science
generally and in the fields bearing on
atomic energy in particular
it is not at all as a species it is
rather as a concrete and constructive if
limited form of those relations of
cooperation among nations which must be
the pattern of the future
let me say again these remarks are not
intended in any way to define or exhaust
the content of any international
arrangements it may be possible or
appropriate to make nor to limit them
they are offered as suggestions that
occur naturally to a scientist who would
wish to be helpful but they leave quite
untouched the basic problems of
statesmanship on which all else depends
there will have been little in these
words that have can have been new to
anyone
for months now there has been among
scientists as well as many others a
concern
often a most confusingly articulate
concern both for the critical situation
in which nuclear physics finds itself
and for the more general dangers of
atomic war
it seems to me that these reactions
among scientists that have caused them
to meet and speak and testify and write
and wrangle without remission and that
are general almost to the point of
universality reflect correctly reflect
an awareness of unparalleled crisis
it is a crisis because not only the
preferences and tastes of scientists are
in jeopardy but the substance of their
faith the general recognition of that of
the value the unqualified value of
knowledge of scientific power and
progress
whatever the individual motivation and
belief of the scientist
without that recognition from his fellow
men of the value of his work in the long
term science will perish
i do not believe that it will be
possible to transcend the present crisis
in a world in which the works of science
are being used and are being knowingly
used for ends men hold evil
in such a world it will be of little
help to try to protect the scientists
from restraints from controls from an
imposed secrecy which he rightly finds
incompatible with all he has learned to
believe and to cherish
therefore it has seemed to me necessary
to explore somewhat the impact of the
advent of atomic weapons on our fellow
men and the courses that might lie open
for averting the disaster they invite
i think there is only one such course
and that in it lies the hope of all our
futures
[Applause]
you can watch any of tonight's american
perspectives programs on your computer
on demand
just go to our website at cspan.org and
click on the american perspectives link
and there you'll find tonight's programs
and recent programs from the american
perspective series that's on the web at
cspan.org
for the next five sundays